we've been doing this new format now a
couple of weeks with this with this new
half-hour format and I have to say I'm
really enjoying it and I don't want to
brag I'm not a braggart that's not my
style but I'm starting to think we got
the hang of it
every once in a while though I like to
make sure that everybody on the staffs
on the same page so now I'm going to
check in with our director Billy ball at
Eno in a new segment I'm calling
checking in with Billy hey Billy hey
Conan what's up I'm just checking in
okay so how's everything looking for
tonight's show
great we're good to go great Oh a quick
question for the cuckoo coconut sketch
am I looking at camera one camera two or
camera three
that's a great question Conan I'm gonna
have one I'm gonna have to ask one of
our camera guys about that in a new
segment I'm Colin checking in with Marty
[Music]
hey Marty oh hey Billy what's up I'm
just checking in okay for the kuku
coconut sketch does Conan look at camera
two or camera three that's a great
question Billy and I'll be happy to
answer it in a new segment I'm calling
getting back to Billy
hey Billy hey Marty I'm just getting
back to you okay
camera three great thanks okay camera
three got it Thank You Marty I'm gonna
let Conan know that he should look at
camera three in a new segment I'm
calling getting back to Conan I know
Billy you don't have to hey Conan hey
Billy I just heard what Marty said I'm
just getting back to you I know it's
okay I already heard camera three yeah
great
Thank You Billy no problem Conan well
that's all the time we have for getting
back to Conan until next time I'm Billy
ballotine oh saying goodnight and stay
groovy America thank you all right I
guess after all that we we don't have
time for the cuckoo coconut sketch that
means I have to debut a new segment I'm
calling lettin down Larry the actor
dressed as a giant coconut
hey Larry oh hey Conan what's up ivy
kuku coconut sketch has been cut huh
all right well I guess that means it's
time to debut a new segment that I'm
calling Larry the actor dressed as a
giant coconut has a meltdown and has
escorted off the lot by security how
could you do this to me
[Applause]